so
what do you have to say about the china
australia deal with bike look again i i
i think that people cannot discount the
fact that i mean i i spent 10 days in
australia i gave i gave a speech over
there it is an amazing country
beautiful people dynamic economy
all dependent not all that's too strong
very dependent on china australia
the biggest port in in australia china
has a 50-year
lease an island i stay on i stayed on
china owns
i mean the the buildings that have gone
up
chinese developers so for australia to
lead 116
countries 116 countries demanding that
the world health organization
investigate launch an independent
inquiry into the origins of the virus
for australia to be in the lead
they knew that they were putting their
their economy
at grave risk and boy have they gotten
some blow back
huge blowback i mean forget wine don't
get me wrong love australian shiraz
lovely good
yum but forget the wine they've china's
now crossed the line and said
cold so i mean they're they're talking
about hitting the australian economy
where it hurts australia is a staunch
ally of the united states
staunch stone staunch biden has
initially said he's not moving those
tariffs
on china oh you heard what he said
yesterday though he says i'm going back
and i'm open to the idea of having to
remove tariffs to
uh uh grow the economy so he's willing
to entertain the idea is that a bad
thing
is that a bad thing okay wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait no no no no no now you're
having two different conversations
because the tariffs have
hurt a lot of our manufacturers yes very
badly
but what i'm what i'm not talking about
the the efficacy of tariffs or not
i'm talking about standing behind
australia
and and and defending australia in this
situation
given the fact that for the first time
in 30 years they're in recession
uh so they're on their knees and still
standing on principle standing up
against china
so i mean i i take my hats off to
australia right now
that they're that they're doing
something they're being kind of american
i hope it can stay that way where's the
united states
uh in on this who i know we pulled out
or trump pulled out is the united states
weighed in on the united states was not
part of the 116 countries independent
inquiry
and what are your thoughts on that do
you think well i i think
china accountable united states i think
it had more to do with the fact that
whether we were in the who or not but i
i absolutely think that an independent
inquiry still
needs to be done yeah and by the way
why isn't anybody asking about vaccines
in in china you've got an entire country
that's
up and running and nobody's talking
about the vaccine and you're saying that
they're not taking the vaccine
saying that they've probably had a
vaccine and have all taken it
and new zealand by the way is choosing
to not take a vaccine until 2020.
i think they're going to skip the
vaccine until 2020. 20 20
2022 i thought they were going to new
zealand has also been
skipped for a year of of kovic for over
100 days or so covet-free
i think they also declared this no
social distancing
new zealand is a completely up and
running covet free
country and i thought i read a headline
that said that they were going to wait a
year
to take the vaccine because they can
danielle what do you think about the
whole thing with ceos mandating
employees to take vaccines 72 think it's
a good idea
to make everybody else in a work
environment feel safer what do you what
do you think about that
can ceos i mean obviously a ceo decides
to do that
do you think that's the right move on
the ceo's end
i really think it depends on the company
kind of what industry they're in in
terms of
what the acceptance rate will be i mean
from the from a business perspective
from a pure business perspective
if you're a company that runs
much better with your offices full of
people yeah
and you need that element you need your
workforce to come back together
yeah and and this is holding back
profitability and revenue
generation capacity i mean
if you don't like it leave again
companies are not in business to be
friendly companies are in business to
make money right so
i mean in america you shouldn't be
forced to take anything
because you're an american and you have
free choice but you're asking me about a
business
and whether or not a business should
compromise its business model
and compromise revenue generation
capacity because
of employees saying no so
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye